[Music]
we think metaphorically we think in
parables we think in ways that are
unrecognizable to other species and
that's maybe fifty thousand years old
right around the time that our ancestors
started doing things like throwing
pigment on the walls of the cave and
this pattern of colors stands for an
animal stands for painting cave
paintings the first sign that this is
not a horse this is a picture of a horse
and that was an incredible leap forward
so we're this symbolic species and our
brain does this unbelievably fancy
symbolism but the interesting thing is
it actually doesn't do it all that well
and it has to do with the fact that
50,000 years is a blink of an eye on
evolutionary terms 50,000 years you
invent all these abstract sort of
concepts you invent the notion of a
moral transgression a baboon could be
pissed off at another baboon who's
bitten him and chase him as a result but
he doesn't frame it as a moral failure
this moral transgression business is
very new so how's the brain going to do
something like that in the eye blink of
50,000 years and you see all sorts of
interesting improvisation --zz for
example there's this part of the brain
called the insular cortex the insula any
normal run-of-the-mill mammal bites into
a piece of food that's rotten and rancid
and toxic the insular cortex activates
triggers all sorts of reflexes you gag
you feel nauseous you spit it out
whatever great way to avoid being
poisoned by rotten food human bites into
rotten food exact same thing that's
where the insular is for but then you do
something different now sit down
somebody and ask them to describe to you
a time they did something totally rotten
and skeevy to somebody else or hear
about some horrible moral transgression
and here's this heartless robber baron
that's repossessing this elderly
Wooden's kidney dialysis machine
horrible morally appalling act and the
insular cortex activates and you feel
disgusted by what that person hey when
you get to humans this part of the brain
that detects toxins and your tongue does
moral disgust as well
aha so that tells you a couple of things
it tells you why you could be so morally
appalled by something that you feel
nauseated by it hearing about that makes
me feel sick to my stomach
having done that leaves a bad taste in
my mouth I just feel I need to wash my
hands of having done that out out damn
spot so it tells you something about
intermixing the metaphors there it tells
you something about evolution when we
came up with this moral transgression
disgust we didn't invent a new part of
the brain in some ways Hey insular
cortex that does disgusting food more of
Wisconsin I don't know that vaguely
sounds sort of like that hey somebody
give me some duct tape I'm going to
strap moral disgust onto gustatory
disgust the insular cortex does that now
what's most interesting thing about that
though is at the end of the day if this
neuron in your insular cortex activates
because this food is fetid and
disgusting and activates because you're
hearing about an act that was morally
reprehensible if it can't tell the
difference we have trouble telling the
difference between visceral disgust and
moral disgust and thus you see things
like we mistake things that are
viscerally very very strange with being
viscerally wrong ooh
they eat different stuff than us they
dress in different ways they pray
differently that's not just different
that's wrong wrong wrong we mistake
feeling disgusted by something as being
a good litmus test for deciding what's
right and wrong
and what we know is somebody's
disgusting this is simply wrong if
somebody else is perfectly normal loving
lifestyle and it's tempting if your
stomach is in a total uproar you know if
it makes you puke you must rebuke we
mistake this
strength of those visceral responses for
abstract moral judgments so it's a very
interesting intertwining the part of the
brain that tells you something about if
this is hot or cold plays a role in
judging to somebody have a warm or cold
personality if you were sitting in a
hard chair versus a soft cushy one you
were more likely to judge somebody is
having a hard inflexible personality
whoa the symbolic metaphorical stuff is
so cool and so human and fancy but we
have trouble telling the difference
somebody else's pain can feel just as
painful as your pain because it's the
same part of the brain that's processing
both
[Music]